hey guys welcome to Westeros weekly the
show that answers your biggest questions
about every episode of Game of Thrones
I'm Phillip Melina and I am flying solo
right now because we are stretched real
thin right now you might have noticed
Avengers endgame came out the same
weekend that the Battle of Winterfell
happened and we're just all exhausted
and covered in blood like everybody
else's right now all our favorite
characters at least so I'm gonna hold
down the fort I haven't slept this is
gonna be interesting
reminder all of our Game of Thrones
coverage is available in our Westeros
weekly podcast feed I get our season 8
content in audio form there earlier than
you can in the video versions look for
Westeros weekly on iTunes wherever you
get your podcasts you crazy podcast
listening senior citizens and also check
out our new MCU podcast called inside
Marvel it has all of our of entries and
game related content all the theories oh
my head just started to hurt immediately
as I started to think about that at the
same time so end that part we got a lot
of great questions from you guys this
week our weekly Power Rankings are
coming we have our kill count
we actually did a kill count which was
like like we're not gonna do a kill
count this we did it's insane I I'm I'm
drunk on on exhaustion and love for the
show and man this episode was so crazy
we're gonna start out the same way we
always do I'm just gonna get into a big
old question that's on my mind on your
guys in mind this question and all our
questions come from my Twitter and start
us and stuff with the hashtag Westeros
weekly but let's get into it from
Twitter at poll tours asks is aria Ozora
hi I don't know who I'm looking at off
screen right now okay according to the
prophecy of the the prince that was
promised which by the way Prince is
actually just us deciding that it's the
prince it doesn't have to be a prince it
could be a princess okay so in the
religion of the Lord of Light there's a
prophesied Savior who is a reincarnation
of the legendary hero Zora hi that
figure is supposed to lead the people
against a darkness by wielding a flaming
sword called light bringer so we've had
a lot of theories about who this could
be
and most people
guess is basically John snow even said
it could be Jaime Lannister he did have
a moment last night that kind of made it
seem like maybe he could be but the case
of Arya being azor Ahai is really
interesting here's why maybe not she as
far as we know was not born under a
bleeding star near salt and smoke
she didn't hatch dragons out of stone
just a lot of weird details with this
prophecy she's not born of the line of
Eris the second and raela like John and
Danny and which is from the woods which
prophecy of this also the show hasn't
really focused on the prophecy part
itself
Melisandre did talk about a similar
prophecy of just in general the princes
promise and also just prophesies in this
show haven't really like been taken so
literally on the show remember most
hundred thought it was gonna be Stannis
Baratheon that was the princess promised
orders or hi so here's my theory okay if
we are just taking the part of the
prophecy that says this hero will return
and will end a long night and will bring
back you know daytime
then that is the the possibility of that
is actually all that needs to be need to
happen in order for someone to become
azor Ahai the stuff about us feeling
like oh well they have to kill their
lover by plunging the sword and whatnot
may or may not be necessary or it might
be interpreted completely different
differently but it's kind of like if we
were to say hey there's a prophecy that
Jesus is gonna return he doesn't
necessarily have to redo the story of
the Bible in order for Jesus to return
so I'm thinking it could be something
like that the biggest reason for that of
course is she brought about the end of
the long night and she defeated the
night king which is kind of what the
whole prophecy is about right but the
other little details you might be able
to like come up with ways to make them
work light bringer is supposed to be
related to the sacrifice of a loved one
ideally like kind of a lover but if you
do think maybe what if light bringer is
represented in the cat's paw dagger
well bran is her her brother who was
almost sacrificed with the cat's paw
dagger all
so the cat's paw dagger itself it was in
the books that Sam was looking at in the
Citadel way back when I it could be
related to the creation of the night
king himself who knows maybe the cat's
paw daggers for luring steel has been
around long a long enough time that it's
in these books along with the concept of
dragonglass being used against white
walkers
could it be maybe that some sort of
fraction of the cat's paw dagger is now
what was actually sorry the other way
around
could it be that light bringer is left
over in some remnant has became the
cat's paw dagger over time it already
had this storied history and now it's
just back and it's exactly the right
weapon still - maybe it's the weapon
that originally made the night King and
then also the weapon that can kill him
so if we go that route then yeah she
would check that off also if we a lot of
people are wondering okay well whether
or not she is the the prince that was
promised or princess that was promised
all right is it totally out of nowhere
that it would be her we got to say no
right this is the only character that
really has had the investment in the
story that would make sense for her to
be the one that could kill the night
King obviously Jon had the investment in
the emotional desire to kill the night
king but in terms of actually being able
to do it this guy is like you know goat
powerful right he's like it'd be the
most unstoppable figure we we have in
this series we haven't seen anyone else
actually preparing for fights at that
level other than Arya
so let's actually review some of those
things right first off even just the
fact that she had Ned Stark as a dad
made it so that she could study some
things that a girl of her time would not
normally be allowed to do if you
remember right at the beginning there
was this debate about whether or not
she's gonna take up sewing and be more
like Sansa and her dad lets her be a
little you know rough around the edges
that's already putting her on the right
path
then surely you know not not much later
actually Syrio Forel teaches her how to
what he calls water dance right and say
not today to the god of death
obviously we spend a whole freakin
season on her with the faceless men and
the wave and they teach her how to be an
assassin and fight without sight they
stop fighting the darkness right which
is what makes it so hard to fight
against all the the white walkers and
the whites in this episode arias trained
against that she also has learned from
both Serio and the faceless man the idea
of kind of like ninja tactics like
moving silently in the scene later where
she is hiding from the whites in kind of
the librarian in the stacks there she is
moving so quietly that the loudest thing
about her is her blood droplets hitting
the ground that shows that she is at
this insane level of sneak a tune which
is a real word just don't look it up
she also has been training for this this
and like very like like easy to see ways
that we've actually been shown before
she had this fight with Brian in season
7 it was kind of like more like a
training play but she used the exact
hand switch trick of the dropping the
dagger and picking it up with the other
hand in that moment obviously it's not
just for shadowing the way that she
ultimately stabs the night king but it's
also showing that she's picked up every
single possible way to continue an
attack against any level of opponent
they also foreshadowed her sneaking up
on someone in the godswood earlier this
season when she does that to John also
Melisandre foreshadowed this back in
season 3 where she reminds she reminds
her about this later that she would shut
blue eyes forever bran also gave her the
cat's paw dagger back in season 7 saying
he had no use for it but I mean very
easily he could have known that she's
the only person that can wield this
thing properly and then the other great
warriors that you might have thought
might have been more appropriate for
killing the night king
they've all been trained for a battle
combat and we learned that there's no
there's no battle going on here against
the night king and his army
we need an assassin and this was a
straight-up
assassination so yeah Arya is kind of
the only person that makes sense to be
able to actually
take out the night king and then yeah
she might be the only person worthy of
considering maybe she is azor Ahai we're
gonna get probably more into that
throughout the week I know Eric's
working on videos too and has it has
more theories there's a lot more to dig
in there but I just kind of want to want
to hear just kind of stutter all over
myself for a second as I think about
what is left for Aria to do I think that
we now we really got to consider is she
going toward Cersei and and King's
Landing Cersei was on her list
we know that Melisandre is original
quote about the eyes of the people that
she you know the eyes that will shut
forever was brown eyes blue eyes and
green eyes
we know Walder Frey has poop brown eyes
Cersei Lannister though and obviously
the 9ks blue eyes Cersei Lannister has
green eyes at least she's written to
have green eyes so is it is she destined
to kill her which is an interesting
question she also didn't use face
swapping yet in this season like help a
swap it sounds like she's using an app I
mean ripping someone's face off and
putting it on her head so that's a skill
that could come into play in King's
Landing the only thing that makes me
hesitate on her potentially killing
Cersei is that they just gave her like
the biggest most badass moment in the
entire series and it to give her also
the killing of Cersei Lannister feels
not only like giving her maybe a little
too much it also is a little bit of a
slap in the face of Maggie the frogs
prophecy where it's the valonqar that's
going to kill Cersei and of course that
just does mean they'll either the little
brother or little sister and REO does
satisfy that but don't we want it to be
Tyrion right that'd just be so much
better so who knows what's actually
gonna happen to the show is about
subverting expectations denying you the
glorious and the you seek for instance
John and Mike King don't even duel they
don't even have this epic one-on-one
battle so I like John and Ramsay didn't
have their like epic fight like
hand-to-hand combat or something Robb
Stark and Jamie never had that even the
moments that we do have it kind of like
when the mountain and open fought you
don't get the results that you want so
that's a big question there is
you know our fingers are cause for a
clicking bull even happening right I
mean I think I think it will happen but
just a lot there's a long way to say the
show doesn't give you necessarily what
you want
that's that my answer the big question
I'm gonna take a sip of water cuz I've
been talking for a long time I'm gonna
if you're watching on the YouTube
version how does it feel for me just
staring into your soul this whole time
you're my co-host this week why don't
you go ahead and take it for a second
alright hey and I'm back okay so here's
another question out of somebody sent us
and I think it's kind of related to the
big question
oh wait I'm supposed to normally someone
is here to hold on you make the question
happen by Raven here we go okay hold on
one sec oh oh but thank you Ray oh you
can't see my arm cuz then you might know
who did it
I wonder Mary why did the god of light
bring back John if it wasn't to kill the
night king interesting question okay day
of I'm not putting the bird back on to
send the question away okay so basically
what John's deal if it wasn't the whole
thing to the show kind of made it seem
like it could be well we got to remember
that it's a little bit like if those of
you saw the feature film Avengers
endgame this this past week there was
with even without spoiling it we can all
talk about we made enough videos about
dr. Strange's plan and we had a lot of
theories about maybe every single thing
that we've seen every loss and every win
is required in order for them to
ultimately win the day at the end and if
you think about things conceptually that
way then John every single act that he's
taken and will continue to take was
required to win the day against the the
battle against the night so if we look
backward then let's remember John Snow
is who won back Winterfell in the Battle
of the bastards without that there is no
Arya killing the night king right so he
played an essential role just like Syrio
Forel just like you know beric
Dondarrion being a barricade
for her for the other whites to just
essentially to by aria sometime a lot of
things for about by an aria time in
order for her to make her move but then
moving forward it actually makes a lot
of sense that his true destiny has a lot
more to do with his Targaryen heritage
and his destiny to potentially be the
king of the the southern kingdoms so in
that sense maybe his role is going to be
maybe he's the one that will kill Cersei
later this season also there's the
option of the azure Ahai prophecy we did
say has a lot to do with you know taking
down a loved one your Nissa Nissa if you
will what if maybe him and aria and
maybe all the star children have kind of
like split some of the prophecy across
them then it would potentially have him
be needed to kill Daenerys Targaryen
right his current lover who definitely
her story is not finished and I also
think we haven't gotten the most badass
moment from Danny yet but we all know
that she's kind of been on the verge of
potentially overdoing it in some way and
he might need to stop her even though
the night king is done you know the
overall the the stability of the of the
realm is not in place right now so John
could be the one that brings that that
stability after or and this is kind of
the biggest bummer but it could be
interesting he's he's kind of a failed
prophet right like Stannis Baratheon had
so much weight thrown behind him and he
had a whole army based on it and he
burned his little girl because of like
all this faith they had and and most of
all most hundreds a little smoke baby
for him and she leached up our friend
Gendry uh and he wasn't special
so maybe Jon Snow is not special in that
way as much as he is just potentially
gonna be a good leader for for his
people the only argument I'll make it of
why I think something really cool is
gonna happen with Jon Snow is he was
brought back right so he was brought
back for something and I don't think
it's happened yet but all right moving
on Phillip letting you take over sure uh
actually have more answers to more
questions but first I wanna take a quick
break to thank our sponsor that helps us
bring Westeros weekly to you every
single week here in new rock stars we
are actually trying to find Kanan can
you get this we're trying to find more
help
does that sound like something we need
yes so we're looking to hire some some
new talent but also some new writers
just people to get involved and also
it's really hard to find people that
work in that qualified like a kind of a
higher nerdier people basically who are
really good at doing the kind of stuff
that we do so we're partnering with zip
recruiter and they're making it a lot
easier for us and they're saving us a
lot of time so if you if you go to them
you can go to zip recruiter comm slash
rockstars you'll see that they can be a
huge help for you they've been a huge
help for us applications are coming in
right now because we already started
posting this stuff but zip recruiter
actually is analyzing each one of those
and is spotlighting the top candidates
for us so we never miss a great
potential match also they're so
effective that four out of five
employers who use them and post on them
get a quality candidate through their
site on the very first day we already
got 40 qualified nerdy candidates for
our job posting in three hours
so at some point I got a switch to that
great all right right now our listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at this
is a web address you should use its zip
recruiter dot-com slash rock stars
getting zip recruiter comm /r o ck s ta
RS so thanks to them zip recruiter it's
the smartest way to hire alright moving
on I I think it's easy to forget in
these episodes where we have a lot of
carnage that you know we lose characters
and if it were any other episode and you
lose one we all be talking about it but
when you lose more than one it kind of
starts to feel like oh well we didn't
lose that many or something no I refuse
I'm alone right now I control this we
are going to acknowledge some characters
that that passed away in this past
episode first of all a lot of whites and
white walkers who were only following
orders and I think it's important that
we kind of acknowledge that those poor
corpses that were raised up against
their will you know we lost a lot of
them also we probably lost a lot of the
unsullied and also the northern armies
who have been great and and trying to be
very helpful we potentially lost all of
the Dothraki Army I actually want to
talk about
that in a second somebody asked an
interesting question about it so I'm
gonna get back to Dothraki I remember
you guys I kind of looked most like a
Dothraki so I also sympathize with them
the most but let's talk about some
specific people and we lost our boy edy
he outlived Grenn and pip and all the
other Night's Watch people who have
names it sound like they're from Lord of
the Rings except John and Sam I think of
all the Nights Watch that's it that's
that's all this loves John Sam it kind
of redshirted him a little bit to still
be around he kind of should have been
like hey let's maybe I don't need to be
in every single fight but we appreciate
that you did it you serve I'm gonna call
you out for some badass things you did
you survived the fist of the first men
you also survived the Battle of Castle
black you also survived that shrieking
of that creepy ass little kid Ned umber
who like no one would have faulted you
if you had a heart attack right there
and died and I'll forget this you were
the last Commander of the Nights Watch
and sadly that means you also died a
virgin so you know it's kind of a
reverse teen horror movie a little bit
because getting laid kept in saves a day
because Sam and Jon lived so you know if
those of you that are waiting maybe
rethink that do not tell your parents
that I'm the reason that you did that
all right next up oh this one got me our
own little badass Lyanna Mormont
she was the smallest warrior who got to
kill the biggest warrior it was a David
and Goliath moment she is now worthy of
being called lianna Giantsbane also Bear
Island now has nobody to roll it and
torment likes bears as far as we know so
you know maybe maybe that if he if he
survives a day he'll go there but give
it up for Liliana Lyanna Mormont back
home everybody can you know take a shot
of milk in Florida all right
up next beric Dondarrion he was on my
death poll listed I guess the throne com
will get results in on that soon so we
have no update right now but I'm just
saying like thank you for dying because
you were on my list and it puts my
little bracket thing forward but wait it
was really interesting that he kind of
Illustrated the idea I was trying to
make earlier about everybody's serving
their purpose that's what this whole
episode was about everyone's row
led them to this moment and I'll get
somebody else who very clearly done a
second but it was so illustrated through
him because he is not a time to bring
him back again he did exactly everything
he needed to do in fact it was
interesting if you take a look at this
this shot I had pulled up you can see
that he died in a christ-like pose which
is if you know famously a symbolic of
sacrificing oneself in order for the
good of others and also I mean if you're
getting real literal here with Bible
references he gets stabbed in the side
which the same way that Jesus was poked
also he's holding the the doorway which
made it very reminiscent of a door
wait bear Rick bear Roy bear the bear no
it doesn't work on that one but but
still give it up her for beric
Dondarrion the guy with maybe the best
voice in all of Westeros I really want
him to read not a book to me let's move
on to this one is is the maybe the most
complete arc that we've had across the
whole series specifically since he
started in the beginning Theon Greyjoy
is it crazy that the guy who Kentucky
Fried kids he now died a good man and a
hero that's in that's insane like he was
at one point he was pea creek now he is
like an actual like you know not a stark
because his hairs too red
but he went out as noble as anyone else
charging ahead in into certain death
instead of hiding and running away which
he's done multiple times even as much as
last season when he jumps off the ship
right so this character I also want to
honestly just give it up to what's his
name Alfie Allen I think that actor has
just like made us fall in love with the
character and hate a character and fall
in love with him again and sympathising
man the journey that this guy took took
this character on was amazing I'm very
proud of the character and and the actor
there and then another character who had
a very long journey and I don't think
people are processing how long her
journey was Melisandre Melisandre was
likely hundreds of years old and I don't
know if you remember this but she was
they tried to poison her way back a few
seasons ago and she survived that easily
so she might have been
practically immortal at least we have no
idea how actually old she is but she
actually lived so long that she is
technically the only the second person
on Game of Thrones to probably die of
old age
the other one been maester aemon so a
lot of people actually were tweeting at
me
you know why does she die in the moment
that she does and it is it does align
with her own prophecy for her own death
she's greeting the dawn and welcoming
the light and finally people are also
wondering why she needed to go to
volantis
did she recharge there we don't know the
exact details we also know that sir
Davos now has the opportunity to pick up
a nice little necklace and become a very
pretty lady but why die in this moment
finally it's because her purpose is
fulfilled
just like beric Dondarrion was she has
been kept alive all of this time to make
these subtle moves and put these
characters just in the right place where
it's it's almost like you know certain
character in avengers endgame where now
you can finally rest I don't think that
she wants to have been alive for as long
as she has she's been you know almost
tortured by by her existence she hasn't
had a happy life she just was put in
place to serve a purpose and by putting
it in putting the work in and doing her
job it's almost like she's given the
gift of death finally you know there's
there's characters that in in both
literature and and well not in real life
so ho jayegi is just in literature
they're torture is being kept alive and
to freedom from that is the best reward
so she actually probably went out on her
best terms possible and especially for a
character on Game of Thrones speaking of
going out on your best terms possible
also speaking of going out in in the way
that ultimately fulfills your true
purpose Jorah Mormont this guy started
out people don't remember this part
either he started out as a spy against
Daenerys Targaryen and then he spent his
whole life the rest of his life trying
to make up for that man this is a bloody
image I pulled her but he died
protecting his Khaleesi and you can see
it in the performance and and in the
characters last choices there that
that's the only thing that matters to
him he's made that very
the whole time specifically this moment
he's been stabbed through basically the
heart right and yet he gets his sword is
his Valyrian steel sword that I got from
Sam and he uses it to prop himself back
up stands tall honoring finally his
house which had which he had shamed
before a house Mormont their motto is
here we stand and here he is saying no
matter what to my last breath you know
I'm standing in protection of my queen
and my Khaleesi that is the probably the
most noble death that we've seen across
all thing if someone just doing exactly
what they wanted all the way through you
know sir friendzone I mean I'm reaching
his end zone I guess he he got exactly
the death he probably wanted I think
that's really interesting I also think
it's kind of interesting that Sam could
be like hey if nobody is using hearts
pain you know I can like a lot of money
for that but and then you know this is
this is a bummer because I'm a I'm an
animal of dude and we lost Viserion guys
Viserion was was also just like just
well trained you know it was his owners
fault that really like set him down his
path he also had that real cool thing
where his face was ripped open and then
he had like leaky blue fire which we've
all been there I just want to give a
shout out to this area anytime we lose a
drag I mean that's that's a big deal but
let's talk about probably the most
impactful death and probably the most
shocking death that happened the night
King so just like Ned and Robb Stark he
actually died way sooner than a lot of
people thought he would but we talked
about it earlier in westeros weekly
episode said and also on breakdowns that
you know it's possible that he that he
would die at the midpoint of the series
because there's so much more of the
season because there's so much more to
happen and also with George RR Martin's
favorite parts being about the shifty
politics of Westeros you know we kind of
like need this thing that is the is so
distracting from who's gonna be on the
Iron Throne to kind of get out of the
way in order to make the Iron Throne
important again I I think it's just
really interesting to point out by the
way it turns out he was dragging
fireproof not re resistant though
apparently but that's that's fascinating
I think some people could think you know
there's more to him than than we even
knew you know somebody asked me if he
was secretly
targaryen Targaryen aren't fireproof and
he's also been established already it's
not a Targaryen so no he's not but it
does kind of like blend into this idea
that there's probably way more story
there to be told with him I'll remind
you guys that the prequel series is
about going into the first long night so
it's possible that we'll see some sort
of more inspiration and motivation for
what he had going on in that show it'd
kind of be smart of them to dangle one
of the biggest mysteries to move as much
of their audience into another show but
also I mean I like that he got to go out
you know raising the roof with it looks
like I'm doing but raising the dead one
more time I do think it's sad that we
didn't hear him say a single word but he
did also spend his last moments with the
other worst conversationalist in
Westeros bran um so you know it but and
also what would have been like a good
enough word like yeah I don't know milk
what man I'm loopy all right let's move
on to it oh gosh we have another
question hold on I need to load up ha
hey this is so worth it at official
underscore CeeLo ass why did the
Dothraki die so easily okay this is what
I was saying earlier where I wanted to
get into the Dothraki a little bit more
so people are like the he just sent the
Dothraki out there to die no it's not
it's they weren't like sacrificing them
they were actually this this moment was
actually supposed to illustrate a point
that the show was making and also
continues to make throughout the entire
episode and I'm sure Eric is gonna get
into the different like levels and kind
of though did the way the battle plays
out I know we talked previously about
the Battle of Helm's Deep and how I had
that concentric circle feeling of moving
and tighter and tighter but the issue is
that when we saw this previously our
heroes planned for battle right they
were trying to fight in terms of war
they gave pieces to the knight king's
army to represent it on a map and they
tried to use traditional strategies
against them
so the strategy they're using in that
moment it's called like a
the ether would describe it is a cavalry
shock attack it's where you send your
cavalry forward purposely ahead of when
the arms are gonna collide to try to
engage the enemy's infantry on horseback
do some quick attacks do a little damage
but really the whole point is to try to
draw the enemy out of their ranks and
have them kind of like come in a more
unstable instead of holding their
formation which is a much stronger way
to attack but that only works when your
army is actually an army of men that is
that has a strategy of their own instead
it's really hard to catch this if you go
back and you replay this moment you when
you see that one Dothraki right before
we all the lights start to go out you
see what he does is he looks up very
suddenly and it's that's trying to
illustrate they're not up against an
army there are not formations they are
trying to use battle tactics against a
force of nature right it is a moving
wall it's it's almost more like a
tsunami literally like like a wave
coming in over their head 20 feet tall
probably and they're here like we're
gonna trick them into breaking ranks
that's not gonna work and that was a
point there and we see that Illustrated
more when the the wave of the Dead
finally hits the unsullied and we see
it's not it's like um like rolling
bodies just stacked you know multiple
feet high not just like a marching force
so I want to illustrate it's not that
the Dothraki were dumb in this moment or
something they just were that immediate
loss that indicates none of this plan is
going to work everything that they did
was for the wrong kind of fight and also
it was used as motivation to mess up
plans even further
Miguel Zapata NIC has directed previous
battle episodes he's my favorite
director on the show he did the battle
the bastards and there's the moment
where Rickon stark enters the the game
enters the battlefield and the plan that
they've had gets thrown out the window
completely because Jon Snow now is
distracted that was what
was happening with Danny and John on the
Dragons they were supposed to wait for
the the night King to be drawn out but
then she sees the Dothraki just wiped
out completely these are the people who
were her first loyal people to her even
before the unsullied I and you know they
represent kind of the loss of Khal Drogo
again but like this is all his people
and she's just like seeing them wiped
out so it needed to be something of that
level to pull her out of the plan to and
just make things that much worse so no
the Dothraki didn't go out like punks
they just were mistaken about they do
but but let's pour one out to the
Dothraki right there and move on okay
this next question kkuk ah it just comes
from me because I would I get really
giddy about certain things as I'm
watching and I wanted to dive into this
if you guys are familiar with with I our
season 6 breakdown of our season 6
finale I got really into the idea of the
light of the seven at this new song that
remains awadhi
composed for that episode and it was a
big deal because it was the first time
that piano was used on the series and it
signified all this change and there was
a lot of storytelling that happened in
in that episode just through the music
so here this is happening again and you
guys probably noticed it that you're
like manda the music is really standing
out to me so I kind of just want to go
into I'm answering my own question here
what's the deal with the music I want to
go into a little bit of why the music
was the design the way it was in order
to help tell the story so they use
something called the Shepard tone it's
this technique where it sounds like a
tone is continuously ringing again and
again but it's actually multiple tones
of overlapping octaves that are fading
in and out but they're also rising at
the same time and they hit a peak volume
at this like fixed frequency if you're
watching the video version I've got a
graphic here that might help illustrate
this but send essentially it's this
ascending tone that is like like hitting
in this ringing way Christopher Nolan
uses the same effect a lot in his movies
what it does for you is it starts
creating this sense of tension and
anxiety it starts to
up in you it's another way to think of
it is when you're looking at a
barbershop pole spinning around or maybe
the way a corkscrew twists it keeps
going up but it never changes its range
and because it's it never concludes it
just raises anxiety up in you I just
thought that was a badass choice that
that they're making that is a subtle
reason why you're like your breath
starts to get short as you're listening
here all the instruments cut out except
for the piano right as the night king
looks at brand it's almost like they're
kind of exchanging something remember
piano is is on this show this the symbol
of a great change about to happen to the
point like all rules are gonna change
everything about the old era is done a
new era is coming in and piano is
showing that to us again if the knight
king successfully kills brand the era of
man is over here and it's almost like
they're kind of communicating something
but then the strings come back and
around this time also the game of
Thrones theme comes back interesting a
different version of it and so when the
strings come back it's almost like the
the previous era it refuses to let go
and that's exactly when Aria is seen
leaping through the air and then when he
catches her all the music drops out we
don't know which of these sounds is
actually going to succeed and come out
if it if it comes out the other way you
know and it's just gonna be piano music
with no knots because everything change
and what we actually hear in that moment
is the sound of White Walkers and whites
just dying and falling the ice
explosions it's a lot like the Sept of
Baelor when that explodes but then who
wins strings for the rest of the episode
in other words the the time of man or
the time of Game of Thrones at least is
not is not going to be lost we're not
moving forward into another change again
that's where mean javadi guys like that
this guy's a badass and his storytelling
just with the instruments go ahead and
like you can look him up on Spotify and
just play all this and you will see that
in your you know minds projector you can
you could watch these episodes play out
just by following the way he changes in
music he is such a badass let's move on
to another question
I lost a bird
hahahaha at Christie law says oh is
ghost alive also I have on here at flute
Kelsey says how's reg all doing people
that like worried about animals just
like me okay so when ghost went into the
Dothraki cha charge
we don't really see him again which
would be worrisome cousin Vic did he die
off screen
he doesn't have why we didn't Elise see
you know dragonglass affixed to his
teeth but I'm gonna say we can assume he
survived the charge just like Jorah did
Jorah was able to come back from it uh
not not the best choice to put him in
that charge though guys I mean like like
save him for put him in the crypts that
would've been great all right but we
also seen the preview for next week's
episode something that looks like a
fluffy white dire wolf behind Sam and it
could be just like a cuddly teddy bear
that he got but I think it's ghost and
then as for Ragle he got a pretty
serious chunk taken out of him by
Viserion and then he kind of crash-lands
with John on him and we don't see him
again and I was really worried and then
also I mean Joe Gunn also I was worried
about because he got swarmed by all
those whites and he took on a lot of
vissarion's flames but we do see him
show up again to comfort Danny as
drawers dying but luckily since force
Aryans down in the preview from next
week when we see two dragons flying
around I think then that would mean that
ragle is also okay and so is dro khan
fingers crossed they're like they don't
get an infection or something all right
next question let's just fly through
some of these my tongue is running out
all right at Carmen monoxide seven says
who is still alive okay so the show did
us some favors by actually showing all
of the living characters at the end of
the episode but the images were dark and
full of terrors so you can really hard
to make them out I'm sure all of you
guys are like playing with your
brightness on here on your TVs I know I
was constantly but in there we see that
John makes it Danny aria Sansa and Davos
those characters are all still alive
in case you were wondering and then the
Crypt this one actually was a little
harder to keep track of Sansa and Tyrion
definitely make it Varys makes it Masson
de Gilly and little Sam
and then maybe this is the like little
girl that the Shireen look-alike from
the episode 2 soup line she by the way
she did not fulfill what she said she
was gonna do protecting everyone down
there but I think she made it then also
just about out there in the battle just
somehow each taking on like a hundred
White's on their own Brienne Jaime and
pod because I guess if you're the
student of bran you're as badass as she
is they all were left standing inside of
Winterfell and Sam is probably still
laying down there crying right now as we
speak but I think at least he's okay
also outside the gate we would have
tormund
Gendry and grey worm they're all still
standing and Tyrion was right he thought
everyone around the fireplace would live
and they did by the way here are some
people that are unaccounted for as far
as I know Alice Karstark she went off
with Theon and bran to the godswood but
then we didn't really see her again so
maybe she's like you know Drax and she's
hiding the place I or something and then
also I think it's so funny that he like
tries to blow himself up is the biggest
most badass soldier or something but Yan
Royce we don't even see him in the whole
episode I feel like he like became like
a turtle and held and just hid inside of
his giant metal what do you call that
shell yeah but who knows where that guy
is I'm sure he's fine though and he
might play a role considering he
controls the Knights of the Vale in what
exactly is gonna happen next week where
they have to fight a whole new battle
well soon all right who else we got
let's see at lahar Frye laughs Roy you
guys need more more you need to help me
pronounce your Twitter handles because I
do not know how to say these all right
but they do have a very interesting
question is winter over hmm okay so the
concept of winter has been associated
with the night king I it he brings it in
we actually literally saw that this idea
of him being able to control winter and
use it to his advantage
he's it in his in the attack but he also
kind of seems like he can control the
weather a bit in general create you know
cold tornadoes whatever
now not all previous winters were
associated with the night king so
obviously they still have a normal
winter as they go so and at the end when
you see Melisandre collapse we do see
that it's still snowing so it's not like
winter is gone it didn't suddenly become
summer I think we're leaving mystical
endless winter magical winter and just
going to traditional winter which is
just like delightful but yeah I think
the long night is over if not winter is
over I what else we got see at GU a UBC
guaca BC what did Aria use to kill the
night king and what did she give Sansa
okay this was a kind of common confusion
because the screen was so dark she does
not give Sansa the cat's paw dagger she
actually holds on to that one herself
which is smart she gives Sansa just a
dragonglass blade the same thing that
everyone else is using so that's what
Arya did use Sansa herself you know it's
good she wasn't giving the cat's paw
dagger because she doesn't even use the
the dragon glass plate to stab anybody
with the pointy end a side note though
the cat's paw dagger is is also kind of
thematically relevant and is appropriate
to be the thing we talked earlier about
how it might have been what created the
night king but also it it's what
partially started the war in the first
season and it's so propria thing that's
ending this war in the final season I
think that that blade is kind of mostly
played its role now but we'll see if it
gets used again at re Williamson where
did bran go when he worked so he tells
Theon uh I'm gonna go now and and he
just like works into a flock of Ravens
and just leaves Theon alone orthey I
hope the unlike knows that that's what
he's doing when he rolls his eyes
backward he's not just like rolling his
eyes at him but so the Ravens that he's
working into they approach the night
king when he's on Viserion and the night
king puts out his hand that's when the
whites start making that body bridge
over the trenches but then brand doesn't
come back from war again until the night
King shows up at the godswood and so he
says the last line of
episode 2 Theon and he doesn't need to
lure the night king out anymore since
he's already been marked and I Kings
already on his way to him so it could be
just as simple as he's just trying to
keep track of the night king at that
time I don't think he's like trying to
send any specific messages or anything
it is possible that you know if we want
to dive into these kinds of theories he
could have walked into the past and
maybe make sure that all his moves were
paying off maybe you know that's when he
told his old self make sure to give Aria
the cat's paw dagger some like that or
make sure to align these characters so
they all end up at Winterfell it is
possible but the show hasn't been doing
that much of that so I think he might
just kind of be just kind of watching
from a better POV honestly but yeah
maybe I hope to be wrong and see if
there's something else that um that is
actually like going on there but I've
got a video question which is great
because I mean somebody else gets to do
the talking I was gonna come from
Stardust it's the social media app that
we use it's like a film and TV lovers
app people share their reactions and
questions on their third video or text
and we'll play one in a second but I
will actually want to remind you guys
this is how you guys are applying to be
the winner the one of the winners that's
gonna get flown out to Hollywood to
watch the Game of Thrones finale with us
so we're gonna actually announce the
first winner next week remember to enter
all you got to do is follow us at new
rock stars and also follow Game of
Thrones on there and then tag etna rock
stars and your Game of Thrones reaction
or your Game of Thrones question and
then you're entered to win this trip you
and a friend and we were kind of like oh
is is you know two people enough and we
were talking about that a little bit and
then we decided let's go ahead and make
it four people are gonna get flown out
so if you're out there and you're
tagging the rock version you're
following us and Game of Thrones yeah
one winner and a friend will be
announced next week and then later on
after that we're gonna now it's another
winner and a friend will also be able to
get flown out and you will join us to
watch the freakin finale of Game of
Thrones that a special VIP screening
that we're doing I'm super excited my
tongue is done so let's play a video
what's up new rock star
my name is Carly Anne and I just got
done watching the third episode I am an
emotional train wreck I'm so stressed
out but I had a few questions for your
show that I wanted to ask so firstly
would John have survived fire from puff
the ratchet dragon thank you Phillip
will unit for that why did the night
king survive the fire that doesn't make
sense
was he a Targaryen I don't know how did
Aria sneak up on him that was next
bubbled ninja and weird Melisandre come
from and why did she have to die please
answer these questions thank you so much
for sending your question to give me a
break for a second most of those
questions I did answer earlier in the
episode but I do want to acknowledge
that John stands up against vissarion
and some people are like what what's he
doing there
is he fireproof I do not think that Jon
Snow is fireproof because again
Targaryen aren't necessarily fireproof
Daenerys Targaryen is the unburned so I
think he's just trying to like take a
stand and realize I need to take this
dragon out of the fight and then he
decides to do that thing where like you
know if I yell really loud maybe I'll
distract it and then I'll stab it not
the smartest move but Tyrians a smart
guy right Jon Jon Snow is just the the
warrior so I don't think he actually I
think he would have been a lot less
brave if he was like I'm not gonna get
burned no I think he can get all burned
up I'll get another question after all
said and done their army is depleted but
yet they're gonna go and attack King's
Landing question mark how is that
possible they have no one left Yeah
right big question well the big question
is something else but important question
we okay I'm just doing like rough like
you know back of used napkin math
everyone a knife cannot be used so if we
had a force of maybe I think was like
thirty to thirty four thousand available
at the batter of Winterfell against the
my king's army we got I gotta say
they're reduced to at least maybe like a
third so I'm assuming we got about maybe
ten thousand left they usually reveal
kind of like a bunch of people were
hiding
so people within the walls especially if
we have about ten
left that would match up pretty well
with maybe about the golden company
that's left of course the golden company
is like fresh trained warriors and you
know the ten thousand I'm counting
includes a little girl with the burn
scars for the other side so it's not
exactly a fair fight but then on top of
that Cersei has Lannister army still
available to her and Kingsguard and all
that so yeah they are completely not set
up in a way where they should be able to
fight at all or have anything other than
maybe the fact that they will have
dragons on their side I do think that
they'll still play a role there there is
still potentially you know a big ol
macro bow and arrow that can that can be
used against them but I think that's
gonna be like the same thing as having
fighter jets in the fight so that'll
help a little bit but here's I'm just a
shot in the dark
what about Dorne right Dorne has it has
been quiet this whole time I mean
they're still probably enjoying like a
nice cool you know 73 degrees or
something down there it's not quite
winter there they have a lot of anger
against the Lannisters and against
Cersei specifically and then you know
it's kind of that idea of the the pinch
maneuver and up in a battle right but
it's the war on two fronts famously used
against Germany in World War two with
with you know the the front from the
West and then the Russians in the east I
it's it makes kind of an unwinnable
battle if you have to split your forces
in two ways it's also been used in Game
of Thrones before maybe surprise Dornish
force comes in from the south and now
that's a battle that can be won and in
terms of when we think that will happen
I'm guessing maybe episode 5 because
that's the other Miguel subhanak
directed episode this season and he's he
loves to do our our battles also I just
want to point out while I'm talking
about him for a second this episode was
not called the Battle of Winterfell a
lot of people thought it was gonna be
called that it was called the long night
instead and I think it's because it
actually did not end up being the big
war episode in in in a way it actually
ended up being much more of a horror
movie
sipar chanock previously did when he did
battle the bastards
that to me felt like his signature like
this is me doing like a battle movie it
had references to Ron and a Kurosawa
films and like
he definitely was trying to show this is
the way that I would love to do a war
film I think this episode he was trying
to say this is the way I would love to
do a horror film and also you know a
thriller and went on a couple different
things but there were references to
Romero instead of you know a spielberg
war film or something so I think he was
trying to do that there so that's the
reason I'm bringing that up is i still
think we're gonna see a more traditional
you know pitch battle or something
coming up soon and i'm hoping that
that's actually we're also we're gonna
see strategy play a big role again and
where tyrion is actually going to make
you know fulfill his ultimate destiny
which is just him killing everybody and
he's just gonna be revealed this is
another re a little badass I don't think
that's gonna happen but speaking of
badass is killing everybody we did do a
kill count this week it's crazy
somehow we kept up with it so I mean it
pulls all this up here here let's take a
look at this I'm gonna be the the map
guy during an election all right so we
got Jaime Lannister in this area and he
killed 16 by himself which is not bad
but Brian actually did 17 kills and I
did that like back-to-back moment which
was pretty badass which is tight but
this is crazy
Theon Greyjoy also at 17 kills which
were all bow and arrow based which is
pretty crazy considering that it was
like just just charging force and that's
I mean the most badass Theon has ever
been of course
Arya not only has the kill of the
episode she has 21 kills in general
throughout this episode and she has such
badass moments right before she slides
down the roof I was looking most forward
to her I felt like she was gonna be
Wolverine on the battlefield and I think
it did kind of pay off I think that I we
got a the thing I don't know is is she
gonna play a role in the battle against
Cersei and the Lannisters at King's
Landing if so I think then maybe we can
finally have her and the Hound
back-to-back you know cannibal a special
you know him throwing her at people and
she just like slices their heads off or
something
but surprisingly we this this was not
the highest number of the episode Jorah
Mormont has 25 kills by like just just
most of them coming just in protecting
Daenerys Targaryen
who herself gets four kills which is
great because it's pointing out you know
she's not just gonna stand there and be
the damsel she's letting draw a
protector but at the same time she picks
up a sword herself and gets in for good
kills is it appropriate to call these
kills of mostly people who are already
dead and then Jon Snow with a
respectable 16 but what we couldn't
count is if there's a moment there where
we see Jon just surrounded by all the
newly raised whites and then we don't
see how he got out of that so this
number could easily be like 360 huh but
we didn't see that so I was only able to
account sixteen and then I'm also just
gonna throw out there you know Danny you
were like oh well if you've killed four
that's cute
Danny with drogon killed hundreds of
whites and then just one more shout out
to the little bear herself Lyanna
Mormont killed one but he was a giant so
he count says I don't know fifteen
sixteen so she's up there with with Jon
Snow too so those numbers often can kind
of giveaway who went to Power Rankings
but let's get into the Power Rankings
cuz you guys know who won did the Power
Rankings just when we only thought about
not even doing it but based on our
Twitter poll last night you guys voted
who had the best showing I think I'm
just gonna give away right now yeah
Arya eighty eight point seven percent of
the vote went to Arya so she got first
place in terms of who won this thing but
it's actually who came second and third
and Power Rankings that I think is
interesting so let's jump to the third
place and that with 2.5 percent of the
vote most powerful character theon
greyjoy crazy right but that said it's
not just because he had all the kills
that he did by himself and protected
brand for as long as he did which was
like he was the the you know the scottie
pippen setting up Arya to make the dunk
like this is this was absolutely a
required role in this but speaking of
absolutely required roles and devoting
your whole life to that that's why I
think second place with four point four
percent of the vote went to Melisandre
Melisandre you might have felt like oh
she was doing cute little things and she
did a
pep talk to our Michael Jordan of Aria
but she has been doing all of these
moves and machinations for the entirety
of the series and things that we didn't
even see on this show so yeah I think
it's fair to say that Melisandre played
this insanely important role and also a
big part of it again just even in this
battle of just buying time to write when
she lights up the trench everything was
required for Aria you can see in there's
a moment where I don't want to make it
seem like Aria was sitting waiting for
just the absolute last possible moment
to attack the night king we see and some
people were wondering how is it that she
she gets to him the White Walkers that
are standing there the generals they're
like oh well they would have seen her
coming you'd see that moment where once
hair moves and then the one up in front
of them his hair moves and happened so
fast that he's not even done turning his
head by the time the next one his hairs
moving his implies that aria is
sprinting at full speed full force she
also runs out of the room that she came
out before she was bought just exactly
the right amount of time to fly through
the air and stop the night king from
killing bran at just the last moment so
then if you're thinking about that and
you realize you know Melisandre bought
them a few more minutes here beric
Dondarrion but bought them a few more
minutes there you see how really it did
everyone was essential coming down to
the last second which is which is
something that actually wants us to do a
video about about everything that for
the whole series that led to this exact
moment of killing the night king but we
tend every week of Westeros weekly with
one last thing that we do which is we
watch the teaser for next week's episode
and I'll just give some quick reactions
to it but let's all watch it together
[Music]
we have won the great pool now we will
win the last war
rip her out root and stem oh okay
so just quick step there I noticed that
looks like Danny's won the respect of
the the northern folk because there's
only a few left probably so it's not as
hard she could go one by one and kissed
each of their babies but other stuff man
they really are pushing Cersei and
you're on so I really hope that means he
dies because he's on my death pool list
pretty soon coming up I think it's gonna
be a lot about how the golden company
comes into play and how it what we
talked about earlier how on earth they
could potentially fight especially if
the dragons we see them there but they
don't we don't see them doing a lot of
damage so they could still be injured
and I think that you know with all these
forces converging now we do have to
remember not only the valonqar prophecy
that I said earlier this could be coming
into play here and somebody could be
going after Circe directly but also the
the thread that's been started with bran
having a secret mission to kill Jaime
and Tyrion it could all start to come
into play here as things are coming
together or maybe the the following
episode is where we'll actually see it
all happen in that spot Nick directed
war episode but guys like my mouth
finished this 20 minutes ago and have
been Mushmouth since that's enough for
this episode of Westeros weekly I have
to get some rest
at some point and also I just need to
process and mourn right over what's
happened thank you so much for watching
and do not forget to supporting actually
and don't forget to subscribe both to
new rock stars on the YouTube channel
and this Westeros weekly podcast but we
started a new one it's MCU based one
it's called inside Marvel get that
everywhere you get your podcast all of
our vendors and game content is on there
just like every other podcast we do all
their stuff comes out their first
because it's so much easier to just
knock out the audio before these fancy
visuals that of me tapping my phone and
you can tweet more questions to us about
Game of Thrones every week with the
hashtag Westeros weekly make sure you
start doing that as soon as the episode
airs because that's when we start
pulling immediately and then you can
also do that member on Stardust just
make sure to tag add new rock stars and
you also get those entries to get flown
out here follow me at fimo on Twitter
and you can ask me questions direct me
directly or you can hit me up
melina on instagram and make fun of me
for the way I look but guys I'm done I
hope you're done - in a good way though
you can rest now and so can I
bye
[Music]